tight jean shorts that's something i  realized when i went to italy something  that just will not catch on in america i  don't care what the [ __ ] it is it will  never catch they cut off right above the  knee and their skin italians love that i  don't get it ferrari shoes cut off jeans  ferrari shoes also mad weird this is the  most fashionable country on the planet  we will wear a cut off jeans shorts we  will not do the tight on purpose  with the hem  yeah the hand is crazy  the hand is crazier yeah that's the  worst part about lacking liking soccer  why is that you like these players and  you like these you're like you see the  way they dress and then you see them  dressing on the way to the bus and  they're like what are you doing super  a-yo it's insane because like every nba  player is swagged out no matter what  super sweat but then you look at the  soccer players and they're just dressed  like average europeans